foreign
let's go to Diana in Philadelphia what's
up Diana
hi Dr John yes how's it going
oh you know It's Always Sunny in
Philadelphia it's always except when the
Astros win the World Series so what's up
oh no thank you for the opportunity for
connecting today I know I recently came
across some of your work and I
appreciate everything you do so thanks
for the opportunity but I am you know
I'm calling today because I've been
struggling with an issue of essentially
not being comfortable with my fiance's
close work relationship with his female
manager okay
um how long have you all been together
uh we've been together now almost five
years five years okay how long has this
relationship been going on
between him and his boss
uh it's like it's like since the
pandemic but like what's really starting
to bother me is like they'll pass you
know two years or so so he switched
positions and so like the first part of
that was you know everybody was working
from home and it was back into the
office so it's kind of been manifesting
like the last you know one and a half to
two years
all right so what do you seeing that's
setting off your alarm systems
yeah so you know I'm like observing like
just changes and like his behavior and I
think like hold on what does that mean
is he like starting to unbutton his
shirt more is he like wearing deep V's
like uh yeah like oh gross don't get any
saving more savings more before work
yeah if he starts wearing deep V's
that's just the sign you're done this
thing's not gonna it's not gonna last
okay good
um okay so he's being more hygienic what
else yeah uh you know I I noticed like
some inconsistencies so I guess the
other layer to this is we also work
together at the same company
so dude you gotta lead with that one so
you're watching this happen I'm watching
it happen yes
so yeah we work together and we're not
the same Department not even the same
office using a different part of the
city even but so like you know we know
each other's jobs we know each other's
backgrounds I'm in a little bit higher
leadership position at the company so it
makes it complex because I don't want to
mix professional with personal but you
know this kind of merges here
um it's already mixed
yes yeah so let's just call it what it
is it's mixed you work you work with a
guy that is beneath you positionally and
I couldn't have said that more awkward
and you're dating him for a long time
and now he
something about that relationship is
that something okay is it something you
know about her or is it something you
know about him
or is it are you watching this thing
happen or do you just not like another
woman having this type of power over him
because she's his boss
yeah I think for me it's like I'm
observing things to travel it's the like
not returning text it's not being able
to answer my call when he's on business
it's the sharing of the rental vehicles
it's you know like the stories where you
know well the whole group's going down
but then it's like three people and not
six you know or you know Well
everybody's sharing the carb and it's
just them you know so and it's like I
know all this this because like I with
an earshot you know way
so it's it's all that that bothers me
you know because like when we are
together any other time it's like we
have good communication we have a very
healthy relationship like
um but it's like when he's on travel I
can tell that it's like well you know
nine to five I'm working and then we're
all going to dinner and then they go to
the bar to 10 30 at night and you know
he will call me but it's like very
distant or you know there's times where
like he won't answer the phone
um you know if they're all at breakfast
in the morning and then he'll say it's
like well it's rude to answer when
you're talking to somebody else and I'm
like well it's me you know so things
like that
foreign
I'm only talking to you here okay
yes
yeah this sounds a lot like your problem
not his
yeah and here's why
um I think he's right if you're having
like breakfast with work colleagues to
sit there at the at the table and here's
it sounds like he is out traveling doing
work
and you want to have the same
relationship the same communication the
same
um
the same
yeah communication patterns that you
have in in when he's there in person and
you simply can't
and I think it is patently unwise to
travel all over the country like yes he
is playing with fire let's make no
mistake about it no question about that
okay I think it's unwise okay
I just think it's unwise
um
and so I think that's worthy of a
conversation both professionally and
personally in your relationship but this
doesn't sound like no dude she's always
draped all over him or she sends him a
bunch of emoji texts in the middle of
the night or he's got a special private
joke collection with her he doesn't have
with me like I'm not hearing any of that
I'm hearing yes
they're both putting themselves in
positions that are uniformly dumb in
today's world it's just dumb right
um
but I hear more I expect him to call me
back when he's working
well he maybe he can't or I expect him
to get up and leave a breakfast or a
dinner and see what I'm saying
look yeah no let me ask more
specifically why haven't you all set up
a time hey right when you wake up call
me I want to be the first call when you
wake up
yeah have y'all set that up
yeah I mean it's hit and miss like
sometimes we'll do that he'll go to the
gym and he'll call me but like the other
thing that has made me I feel like more
uncomfortable too is that
um you know like there'll be times where
like there they work side by side every
day in the office uh typically prior to
like the pandemic
um we're lucky we're in a hybrid
situation now and they're like the only
ones typically
um in that section of their office so
like you know we'll he'll call me you
know at lunch time to say how's your day
going and then you know I'll hear her in
the background or she'll ask like who
you know he's talking to and like there
has been times where like he wouldn't
even end the call list and I love you
because he didn't want you know he would
say oh well I didn't want them to know
him on a personal call
and but I'm like that's like silly
because like that's like an unrealistic
expectation that you can never take a
personal call and it's not like it's
over excessive
so like it like that's like hurtful like
it almost feels to me like
he was trying to segregate like my his
relationship with me from like his work
relationship
um at science
so here's the best thing you can do
moving forward
you can be very very honest with him in
less in an accusatory way you're doing
this and you're doing this
but a very vulnerable
make this all your problem not his
yeah here's how I and I have I have
approached it like that and like that's
where you know I have been
um you know like trying to like go down
that route and be like listen I know uh
you know I I admit to like even in my
pre I did have infidelity in my previous
marriage and um that wasn't like the
deal breaker so I feel like I am
hypersensitive
um him and I were you know co-workers
before we were even together so like the
realism the whole work wife thing you
know it's real but at the same time like
I would never tell him you can never
talk to another woman or you always have
to drop everything for me like I don't
feel that way like I I have to
um be able to interact in society and I
would never say quit your job because I
don't like someone you know but it's at
the point where when I do try to talk
about it and you know take
accountability like he'll just get super
angry and then like his anger then like
fuels me to think like well is there
some truth to it so you you are you are
absolutely right yeah absolutely right
there yeah a conversation my wife and I
had recently was
um I told her
I want to talk more on the phone
with you and the kids when I'm traveling
and what I realized was she was trying
to really be uh the most supportive
spouse she could be
and that was man I don't want to call
you if you're on stage I've I've been in
the wings about to go on stage and she's
called and I've taken the call just
because I just think that's fun and she
can hear the crowd she's like what are
you doing it's like I'm about to go on
stage and she's like oh my gosh get off
the phone and or my kids have calling me
as I as I'm walking into an interview
for a radius right so she has in an
attempt to love me better
minimized phone calls she doesn't want
to bother me she's and so I said hey I I
wanna I need more contact on the road if
I call you we know that I'm trying to
reach out I'm going to connect if you
get a moment just call I'd love it when
you call and if I can't take it I won't
take it
and so here's the deal she was trying to
love me the best she could and then I
was able to say hey here's what my need
is in this season and it might be that
one day I'm like hey I need you to call
Les like I've it's just too wild on the
road right now
um and so all I have to say is this
you can just speak your needs as you
need them and I don't like that he's
getting all mad and angry and frustrated
that is that would set off my alarms too
but here's the deal you can't control
that you have to make a choice
and you've been burned again before
you're starting to feel like you're
getting burned again
and I would trust your feelings and I
would trust those alarm systems that are
going off
I would also be very very real I would
ask my uh demand evidence from my
feelings the way I'll say it
mm-hmm is he cheating is he about to
cheat is he getting pretty damn close to
cheating
or is it my alarms to people cheating
going off and those don't have to be
mutually exclusive but here's the deal
at the end of the day you got to make a
choice
and if you go through this relationship
you go into it I can hear it on you
you feel like you're losing it
you're gonna get married and you're
going to find yourself in another mess
again
less because you have a husband that or
a fiance that as a boss is a woman
more so you said hey here's what I'm
struggling with here's some of my needs
and he got pissed
yeah exactly like I'm more disappointed
in the fact that like he you know
wouldn't just even say I'm Chasing
Ghosts right I control that like but the
fact that he just wouldn't honor
um and at least like just say hey you
know I get how you're feeling and let's
talk through this or is there some
Middle Ground I mean I even went to the
point where it's like like you said I
take accountability maybe I'm I'm wrong
and so I'm like maybe I you know maybe
we meet if she's important to you I want
her to be important to me and that's
fair I mean there's other people that
you know we have common friends other
co-workers other female co-workers
um and like even the first time I met
her it was like very awkward like she
wouldn't even introduce herself me for
the first five minutes I had to
introduce myself
um I've extended the olive branch I said
hey I know you know I Mentor a lot of
different people in in our company I've
invited her to come have coffee with me
um you know participate with training
session with my team and she's really
always been standoffish and it's like
even I would feel better if you know I'd
call and I did hear her in the
background she's like oh you know say
tell Diana I said hi you know things
like that but it's it's very it's very
like hard for me to feel the Comfort but
she doesn't owe me anything I feel like
I'm more disappointed and slightly
betrayed with him are you done you know
with the relationship
no no I mean if I was was I wouldn't be
like looking to fix things
okay the things you're now you're
telling me
the way she responds to you
um the way he responds when you bring
things up
I think you're right
I think you're right
I think your intuition's right and
earlier in this call I said this is your
your problem to deal with it is but I
think your intuition's right
something's not okay
right
and um
yeah like I feel like do because you
mentioned like having that like evidence
base that's like you know I feel like
it's not like that full-fledged Affair I
feel it's just like early now you're now
you're guessing and you're hoping I'm
guessing
you're guessing you're hoping
yes because you don't think
psychologically and spiritually and
emotionally you can handle another
somebody else cheating on you
Maybe
[Music]
and so here's your path forward it's not
a pretty one
um
it's a pretty direct conversation with
him
and before I had that conversation with
him I would be very very specific about
your needs
and man if somebody feels awkward saying
I love you at the office I I'm okay with
that it's fine I don't want to be weird
um
that sounds like a strange work
environment but so be it
um I
be very specific here's what I need from
you moving forward
and before that conversation okay let me
back up here
you only have one path forward it's
going to be very uncomfortable and it's
going to be you directly asking are you
having an affair are you cheating on me
and this isn't a time for Rage or
um
uh
he's got to have a safe place where he
can tell the truth
the rage will come
Madness and anger will come
but this needs to be a safe factual
conversation are you having an affair
and if he gets mad and throws a fit say
I'm going to end this conversation right
now because you're not having this
conversation like an adult and we'll
Circle back and have this tomorrow
but I need you to be honest with me
I need you to have enough dignity and
respect for me
just as a person
as your friend as somebody you say
you've loved some I've been with for
five years just tell me if you're having
an affair tell me
this is a moment to not be a coward a
moment attack character and if you're
not having an affair
and you want to continue to be with me
and you want to get married to me and
spend the rest of our lives together
here's what I need
and you've got to be real specific and
the reason this is going to be gnarly
Diana is he might say yes I am having an
affair
he might say I haven't had an affair but
I've got feelings for my boss
he might say no I'm not having an affair
and the fact that you are are accusing
me uh makes me want to be with you
anymore
all those things can happen and the only
the only
offering of light I can give you in that
moment is that was gonna that was gonna
come crashing down at some point and
it's better to do it now before you are
legally married
my hope is he says I'm so sorry
no I'm not cheating on you never have
I don't know how to act in this work
environment it's weird
and I'm trying to be a good employee I
also want to be a good
um fiance to you I want to build a life
together I'm just kind of over my head I
don't know what to do and you as a woman
who is higher up in the company than he
is who has had men reporting to you you
can walk through here's what's
appropriate here's what's not here's
what it's okay for you to say and here's
what's not
um
and go from there but there's no way
forward without some really Direct
really direct hard on the nose
conversations no beating around the bush
no like well I've been thinking about
are you cheating on me I need to know
and I deserve at least that much
and if not and you still want to be with
me
let's be very clear what I need moving
forward and tell me what you need moving
forward
let's work on this together
I'm so sorry Dan hey let me know how
that conversation goes I want to know
what he says and where things stand